منتخبات كره القدم اتعكس الشخصيه الوطنيه
لبلادها وهذا تصريح شهير لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه الاسبق هنريكسنجر وفي المجتمعات
اللاتينيه مثلا انتشار الفساد وغياب
الرفاهيه للطبقات الدنيا يجعلان الايمان
ابي ان القدره على الافلات من العقاب ليست
شيئا معيبا للغايه اما في الدول ذات
القوانين الاكثر حزما اوروبا مثلا الامر
مختلف والتدليل على الامر يمكن المقارنه
بين موقفين متشابهين بردود افعال مختلفه
في الفن
1986 استخدم النجم الارجنتيني مارادونا
لاحرازي هدفا يده وهذا الهدف هو الهدف
الشهير كان ضد انجلترا حين ان لم يشعر
الارجنتينيون اولا مارادونا بانهم مضطرون
لتبريد الامر وبات هدفا اسطوريا يعكس دهاء
كرويا على الجانب الاخر وصلت فرنسا لكاس
العالم في و10 على حساب ايرلندا وبفضل هدف
حاسم بعد لمس المهاجم الفرنسيه هنري بيده
الكره مرتين اعترف هنري بخجل بما فعله
ودفعت الفيفا خمسه ملايين يورو لايرلندا
لثنيها عن مقاضاه المنظمه الكرويه الدوليه